[Musik]
Ja, also denke ich, dass Wikipedia mit dem,
was ich als echte Fake News bezeichnen würde,
fast keinen Einfluss auf Wikipedia hatte, und
der Grund dafür ist, dass die Wikipedia-
Community von qualitativ hochwertigen Informationen besessen ist.
Was eine gute Quelle ist, ist eine
zuverlässige Quelle  Was das
Hobby der Wikipedia-Community ist,
darüber endlos zu diskutieren, und wenn
Sie eine Geschichte nehmen, erinnere ich mich an eine Geschichte,
die
während der Trump-Kampagne viral wurde und besagte, dass die
Überschrift Papst unterstützt Strunk war, die
viral wurde und
tausende Male online geteilt wurde  Aber das ist die
Art von Dingen, auf die die Wikipedianer
nicht hereinfallen würden, dass sie es sich ansehen würden
und sie würden sagen, zunächst einmal
Papstes nie unterstützte politische
Kandidaten, und dann soll dieser bestimmte
Papst ziemlich berühmt sein, wie ein
wirklich netter Kerl, hoffe es  Es sieht nicht
so aus, als würden Sie Trump unterstützen, und
dann schauen Sie sich die Quelle an und sagen, oh,
aber das ist nicht einmal eine echte Zeitung, oder
Sie wissen, dass Sie einige Überprüfungen durchführen und so  also
es schafft es überhaupt nicht in Wikipedia,
genauso wie die
virale Verbreitung von Fake News Menschen
sind, die keine Wikipedianer sind, sie sind keine Nachrichtenjunkies,
sie sind gewöhnliche Menschen, die
ein geringes Interesse an den Nachrichten haben, und sie
etwas sehen, das sie entweder begeistert
oder erschreckt, und sie teilen es
ohne viel Nachdenken, und das ist ein
Problem. Ich denke, für Wikipedia ist das größere
Problem mit der aktuellen
Medienlandschaft und all den Problemen des
professionellen Journalismus die
Anzahl der Arbeiten  Journalisten wird
abgelehnt, und das ist besonders auf
lokaler Ebene, und Sie können die
Geschichte einer lokalen Gemeinschaft nicht schreiben, wenn sie
nie gegründet wurde
[Musik],
Sie müssen unterscheiden, zwischen
welchen Donald Trump sein Bestes tut,
um die Unterscheidung zwischen gefälschten
Nachrichten auszulöschen  minderwertige Medien und Dinge, die Donald
Trump nicht mag, und ähnlich
muss man es in die andere
Richtung sagen, nur um zu sagen, nur weil ich dem
zustimme, macht das nichts  Es ist Qualität,
und Sie wissen, was wir betrachten, sind
ziemlich altmodische Standards, wissen Sie
, ist es eine legitime journalistische
Organisation, führen sie Korrekturen durch, Sie
wissen so etwas, aber natürlich müssen
wir wachsam sein, wir haben es ist eine neutrale
Sichtweise  ist einer der grundlegenden
Mieter von Wikipedia, und es ist wichtig,
dass wir versuchen, sachlich zu sein, selbst wenn es um Ich
weiß nicht, Adolf Hitler geht, Sie
wollen nicht einfach
ohne Grund ununterbrochen negativ sein, Sie wollen
immer sachlich sein, aber ich  Ich denke, in der
Wikipedia-Community sind die Werte der
Community sehr stark darauf ausgerichtet
, und ich denke, selbst Mitglieder
der Community, die
sich als Anti-Donald-Trump bezeichnen würden,
glauben, dass der effektivste Weg
, Anti-Donald-Trump zu sein, darin besteht, rücksichtslos
sachlich zu sein  Sie müssen keine Voreingenommenheit haben
, und das ist wirklich
interessant, wissen Sie, wir haben das in
der Vergangenheit bei strittigen Themen gesehen, Sie
können Leute haben, die sagen, es ist wirklich sehr
imp  Es ist wichtig, dass wir die Fakten richtig verstehen,
und selbst sehr ideologische Menschen glauben,
dass sie mir zustimmen würden, wenn alle die
Fakten so verstehen würden wie ich